I mean who would ever have expected
theology to rear its head once more in
the in the technocratic 21st century
almost a surprisingly perhaps as of mass
revival of neoplatonism why is it that
my local bookshop at home has suddenly
sprouted a section labeled atheism
I might even who knows we're now
planning one you know marked empiricist
skepticism with Anglican leanings the
one on earth is going on here I mean why
what is another way you know why just as
we were apparently confidently moving
into a post metaphysical most
theological even post historical era has
the God question suddenly broken out
anew can one simply put it down to
fanatical Islamists and falling towers I
don't really think we can at least not
for the most part certainly ditch
consists is taste for religion didn't
sprout from the ruins of the World Trade
Center that's just cause you click
mistaken it's true I think that quite a
lot of the debate took its cue from
there an ominous fact I think since an
intellectual debate is not best served
when it Springs from grief hatred
hysteria humiliation and the urge for
vengeance along with some deep-seated
racist fears fantasies but 9/11 wasn't I
think really about religion any more
than the war that's been waged where I
come from
more island for the past 30 years was
about papal infallibility for wanting
radical Islam as I've said before
generally understands exceedingly little
about its own religious faith and
there's also good evidence surely that
its actions are largely politically
driven not theologically driven but I
think there's a deeper issue at stake
here which is the Islamic fundamentalism
confronts Western civilization not only
with blood and fire but with the
contradiction between the West's own
need to believe and it's chronic
incapacity to do so it's that paradox or
conflict which as it were Islamic
radicalism writes large it brings out
something embedded something
contradictory embedded in Western
culture itself I mean the West now
stands eyeball-to-eyeball with a
full-blooded as you like metaphysical
foe for whom absolute truths and
foundations pose utter no problem
whatsoever I mean would that they did
would they did at just the point at just
the point where a West in the throes of
late modernity or post modernity or
everyone solid escapes art by on
believing as little as it decently can
get away with in post niche and spirit
it appears to be and I've touched on
this theme before appears to be miserly
undermining its own erstwhile
metaphysical foundations with its unholy
melange of practical materialism
political pragmatism moral and cultural
relativism and philosophical skepticism
all this so to speak is the price you
pay
affluence and that might not matter so
much except that suddenly you then find
yourself as I say eyeball-to-eyeball
with an enemy who seems metaphysically
speaking foundationally speaking as it
were much more resourceful and better
equipped than you do in the word since
you're in the process of arguing all
that away it's not quite to go back
again to something that I've talked
about before it's not quite that I mean
there does seem to be an irony doesn't
as I said before that just at the point
where the West seems to be abandoning
grand narratives a new one that of the
which no doubt sets the tone for the
next century or so that the war between
capital and the Koran reading of the
Koran broke out at that very point to
confound as it were the death of history
merchants that's an IRA entirely worth
noting but to put it that way I think
misses the connection between the two
but just as it were a contingent fact
that the one happened and then the other
did announcing the death of history
meaning of course that capitalism will
only ever be the EM ever the only game
in town is the intellectual or one
intellectual reflex of a real life
campaign of Western global domination
which then triggers a backlash in the
form of launching a new grand narrative
of so-called terror so that as it were
the very act of attempting to close down
history involves riding roughshod over a
number of people who then by backlash
launch a new kind of grand narrative
leaving you in the unlikely situation of
having as it were opened up a new grand
narrative precisely in the attempt
to close walk down let's talk about a
Western Campaign of global domination is
not of course some lurid leftist
rhetoric but the stated plan of America
in the new century the stated plan of
the neoconservative gangsters who
hijacked the White has that in other
words of that American assured and
unassailable American dominium global
Dominion would be the agenda from now on
one of many reasons of course why the
nation has been so utterly discredited
in the eyes of so many throughout the
world so closing down grand narratives
in the very opening them up in the very
act of closing them down is as I think I
said before not a new phenomenon it
happened with Hegel for example no
sooner had the glad tidings been
announced in the West that so-called
grand narratives were now definitively
over and we could all engage in micro
politics namely politics so small as to
be invisible no sooner had that happened
than the West's own predatory political
actions not just recently but for a long
long time in the Muslim world helped to
give birth to a new kind of grand
narrative that of Islamic radicalism it
has always been to be sure again I think
I've touched on this previously there's
always been to be sure a kind of
built-in contradiction in capitalism
between what in old-fashioned Marxist
terms very we we might call a
superstructure in other words modern
market societies tend to be inherently
secular relativist pragmatist
rationalist materialistic not just as it
were that they adopt these philosophies
or ideologies haven't chosen them
from among a row of others but there's
something these ideas these values and
beliefs are as it were built into a
certain kind of secularizing market
rationality problem being of course that
those values are then bound to exert a
certain subversive influence on the
religious and metaphysical
superstructure which exists among other
things to legitimate the very market
order itself that is I think a
contradiction from which capitalism is
absolutely incapable of fundamentally
escaping though it can find various
strategies from the gofer as it were
closing the circle here I mean you know
you just can't really with any
plausibility appeal to the Virgin Mary
or the Platonic forms Bank just doesn't
have any kind of conferencing ring to it
at least you know but you might find
yourself you see ultimately when your
backs to the wall in a situation where
something like that it's like that
incongruity has to take place though
otherwise you're forced to question
whether you're super structural or
metaphysical values or foundati those
are really meshing any longer with what
you actually do and when what you
actually do no longer meshes with what
you say you didn't that's to say with
the ways you describe what you do to
yourself when in short you have what the
linguist officials would call a
performative contradiction of a level
however here of a whole society then you
are annoyed ideologically speaking in
big trouble when there's not sufficient
fit between what you do and how you
explain that to yourself or to others
you have to as it were may be wheel in
some new kind of discourse which will
account for the gap between them the
meta physicians of the religious right
are of course seeking to put that
superstructure back in place which is
one of several sense
in which postmodern relativism breeds
redneck fundamentalism they are of
course size of the same coin they paint
each one another constantly into a
corner yes they bounce off each other
all the time what's happened however we
did the advent of Islamic terrorism I
think is that some of these built-in
contradictions in the West have been
dramatically highlight highlighted it's
not just a matter with two antagonists
squaring up to each other across the
globe it's a matter of one of them
Islamism so to speak highlighting
showing up certain inherent conflicts
and problems in Western liberal
societies themselves I should however
add of course there's always there's
always the exception of good old America
in contrast you know two godless Europe
that America seems to have found quite a
good job I think how exactly of managing
this contradiction between you know
secular base and metaphysical
superstructure as at once you know one
of the most grossly materialist but also
one of the most high-minded ly
metaphysical societies in the world the
the metaphysical pitch of American
political rhetoric rhetoric is
astounding to European as I think I
might have said before America sounds to
us full of the kind of sonorous solemn
hand on heart rather earnest arnoldii
and discourse of God
freedom nation and family that
particular poisonous little social unit
much beloved of advertisers and the
chosen people versus the powers of evil
nor lakhs
which type said before tends to say is
very different I think from a standard
European kind political discourse but
which seems this is my point which seems
to co-exist for the most part easily
enough with the discourse of postmodern
skepticism or you know consumerist
hedonism somehow Forrest Gump and Kill
Bill go together you know some parts of
the divided but nonetheless the same
type of sensibility there is of course
let me just touch very briefly on a huge
contradiction and which I won't say
about there is of course another
inherent contradiction in liberal
capitalism that it's the fact
exacerbated by the war on terror the
fact but always there a running
incipient contradiction then suddenly
dramatically projected onto a global
stream namely the fact that violence is
necessary in defense of freedom what
will always risk stopper in that freedom
in the process so that if you push that
process too far you genuinely have to
ask what is it now we're defending and
it may be that that's precisely one of
the strategies of
Islamic radicalism to push you where you
find active defending your society
you've got no values left to defend that
might be the ultimate Victor
economic liberalism I mean good
old-fashioned possessive individualism
rides roughshod over peoples of Nations
and communities but triggers in that
process just the kind of violent
backlash that social and cultural
liberalism are late least equipped to
handle this as it were is now a
contradiction you might say within
liberalism itself between its economic
and political practice in the world
backlashes that that breeds and then the
attempt of as it were a more socially
minded or cultural liberalism to respond
to that in the sense to them terrorism
the war on terror so-called highly
highlight certain contradictions endemic
in
haunting liberal pluralism can't help
involving certain indifference to the
substance of belief values of course but
it's also a problem for it not least in
this kind of political crisis and
because of course liberal societies
don't so much hold beliefs as believe
that people should be allowed freely to
hold beliefs such cultures display are
supposedly creative indifference to what
people actually believe as long as they
can get on with the business of
believing it and importantly as long as
those beliefs don't jeopardize the very
principles of freedom and tolerance
which underpin this liberal liberal
society is someone Bonin is leaving
believers to get on with it
unmolested rather as the English would
certainly by you if you were bleeding in
the gutter not because they're
particularly hard-hearted but because
they would like to interfere with your
privacy
so the problem problem is that such a
society Foster's necessarily and in many
ways for the good a kind of purely
formal or procedural approach to belief
which involves as it were keeping two
strong identities at a certain ironic
arm Smith entertaining them allowing
them to flourish but keeping them a
certain ironic liberal society is one
long unruly eternally inconclusive
argument I say eternally I suppose
modernity as a period liberal modernity
is a period in which astonishingly we
have to come to terms with the fact that
we disagree on fundamentals strange
indeed not that as we might have thought
we agree on fundamentals but we differ
on the details but that although almost
everybody agrees that burning people
innocent people slowly over fires is not
the most desirable thing to do we can't
agree on what moreover we will probably
have to just put up with that situation
for a long time that however is not an
easy thing to put up with because not
non agreement non consensus for a
liberal society is dangerous it can also
it means conflict and conflict can break
out in more physical forms that then can
threaten the very basis of that society
itself so there's a long-running
inconclusive eternally conclusive
argument which is called liberal society
and that's a source of value but it's
also a source of vulnerability and
particularly where as I say you're up
against people
what it was belief or a quite
foundational absolutely that's fun of
course to say that liberalism liberals
have to be lukewarm liberalism that's a
mistake I think about the nature of
liberalism liberalism doesn't have to be
lukewarm
I mean classical liberal liberalism can
be passionate about its own principles
without violating its belief in
tolerance and respect I mean you can be
sort of suitably closed-minded about
being open-minded and how closed-minded
about being open-minded you should be is
now a big an issue of high of contention
may not always be put in that way but
you know what we are allowed to do or
reject in the name of preserving freedom
or open-mindedness is of course an
enormous ly important political this
year quite a lot of post-modernism I
think is is in some ways an heir to this
mighty liberal tradition although it
might be described as as liberalism
without subject it's but a lot of
post-modernism is open to beliefs not as
with the best kind of liberalism
despite the principled repugnance a
certain principal repugnance but because
of a sort of marketplace indifference to
them and that's not to suggest that you
know bin Laden couldn't profit from a
healthy dose of postmodern skepticism
self-irony and anti foundation ISM
course he would
yes but there are dangers there too as
far as this question of the purely
formal or procedural nature of
I mean there is for example think of the
difference here between tolerance in
classical liberal sense and forgiveness
which obviously have certain kinds of
things in common but you know a certain
kind of liberal or more so postmodern
tolerance doesn't really care what you
believe in
whereas forgiveness means of course
being deeply injured really caring about
it
seeing with cold-eyed realism the worst
about both the offense and the offender
yet despite this managing to embrace him
or her in a solidarity which is far
removed from some kind of spiritual less
if there economic liberalism creates a
spiritual and material wasteland in
which people feel quite often they must
cling to some fairly exclusivist
doctrine or the bottomland form of
identity if they're to preserve the fate
of the faintest notion of who they are
that sends to economic liberalism
generates several forms of
fundamentalism most a lot of those
people who feel those anxieties because
of course fundamentalism is really about
deep deep anxieties as does hatred as I
suppose for the most part the effect of
anxiety most of those people can see
well enough but the liberal pluralism is
really for those who don't have to worry
about who they are it's all very well
being a liberal pluralist if you don't
if you don't have to carry your identity
as a painful burden on your back all the
time which of course is the unlikely the
welcome a lot of people who are
oppressed
were made unhappy by their situations in
various ways and the point for those
people is not to then assert some
essentialist identity some essence of
identity
I am incidentally a card-carrying a
sensuous but to get to get to the point
where like the other people they no
longer need to worry about who they are
to create the kind situations in which
that is no longer the problem for or all
in which they can as it were become what
they desire to be at the same time and
another another reason why is it were
Western capitalism late capitalism is
lackadaisical about the league is that
it seeks to secure for itself the kind
of automated or built-in consent which
doesn't really depend perhaps all that
much citizens actually think we might as
it were particularly the left might be
in danger of overestimating the
importance of ideology in that respect
capitalism isn't the kind of life form
which exacts too much spiritual
commitment from its citizens you know as
long as they get out of bed consume and
pay their taxes and refrain from beating
up police officers you know as long that
is to say as the system's hegemony is
confirmed and reproduced in fairly
practical material ways then what goes
on in the hearts and heads of the
populace is a strictly secondary affair
as long as though they can believe
whatever they like obviously certain
beliefs will be subversive dangerous but
there's a lot of lassitude in that
belief is not probably it's probably not
what keeps the system taking over as
belief is what keeps the Lutheran Church
ticking over
no idea you know what late there's a
sense in which late capitalism is
intrinsically agnostic and this makes it
look particularly flabby when its
paucity of belief comes up against an
excess of it and not only an an external
excess form of foreign enemy but of
course internal excesses - in the form
of the various homegrown domestic
fundamentalisms which the system tends
to breed the very pluralism to which you
appeal as a potent source of spiritual
authority has a fatally weakening effect
on your pull on your political authority
not least when you're up against the
kind of bigots who regard that pluralism
as a source of moral weakness I mean the
idea apparently beloved of some
Americans that you know Islamic
radicalism radicals do what they do
because they're envious of Western
freedom one heard a lot of lacked in the
wake of 9/11 is about as persuasive as
the idea that you know all Islamic
radicalism want to do your city and
cafes smoking dope than reading view
Delors
trouble is then that freedom and
democracy involve a degree of conflict
and diversity which might not which some
might think is not the thing you really
want you know when you're up against
people who are trying to dismember you
on the other hand as I pointed out
before if you surrender freedom and
democracy then what exactly is it that
you're clinging to what is it you have
to defend multiculturalist ideology we
do with it sometimes rather blindly
formalistic embrace of belief as some of
belief as such once again rather like a
certain kind of classical liberalism
multiculturalism tends to as it were
acknowledged the fact of belief the fact
of a variety of beliefs rather than
enquiring substantively into the belief
itself in doing so it makes a very
common mistake mistake made by both
smartness Masaccio imagining the
astonishing idea that somehow diversity
is a good in itself somehow a Trojan 80
or multiplicity you know all words with
an S on the end cultures are
intrinsically superior to
or unity I mean I you know may just be
eccentric but the idea of having 93
fascist parties around the place instead
of a single one you know I mean I'm a
bead really pre postmodern here in my
dislike of heterogeneity or you know
breeding a multiplicity of social
classes you know to make the ones we
have look very impoverished this
extraordinary idea really quite a
universalist docma on the part of some
post modernism that multiplicity is
always an everywhere so superior to the
opposite multiculturalist ideology
because of it's sort of arm's length or
hands off or ironic relation to this
diversity of beliefs of course tends a
lot of the time to want to diffuse them
just as I think it's Alistair McIntyre
points out that the cultural relativism
relativism or moral relativism is among
other things a way of avoiding conflict
as to say if our positions are simply
incommensurable you know if you think
that patriarchy is an oppressive social
system I think it's a small town in
upper New York State you know then of
course we are not conflicting we have no
common ground on which to do sir our
positions are simply incommensurable and
therefore we can pass up to something
else moral relativism is an attempt at
if he was conflict among other things
and so among among other things I think
is is is its multiculturalism it
multiculturalism is for example
extraordinarily Chloe of calling other
people's beliefs you know Aaron nonsense
or unmitigated garbage you know it
surely one has the right to do
a huge amount of garbage around the
place that we have to name for what it
is why not one of the most applicable to
aspects of Chris's Hitchens's God is not
great superbly stylish is is that
Hitchens
believes that religion is disgusting and
has absolutely no qualms about seeing so
I mean he may be right or wrong about
that but he's uh he's properly unafraid
to announce it and to take the
consequences of it including getting
slapped off by me his his old comrade
societies for which abrasive criticism
is automatically abusive and the
American abuse of the word abusive is
now up to the point where you know any
mildly critical remark becomes abuse you
know a sure sign of mind control if ever
there was one such societies clearly
have problem a multiculturalism doesn't
help there so in a certain sense what
I'm arguing I suppose is that the
surface of belief is what late
capitalism has actually helped to spawn
partly as I say because I that it's a
sort of destructive global behavior to
which that superfluity of belief ISM is
a rather ugly and pathological reaction
but also for another reason namely that
a rash a trend of rationality that has
grown to you know dominative and
calculative and instrumental and all the
sort of Frankfurt School cliches is
simply too shallow a soil in which a
reasonable kind of faith can take root
and flourish and the consequence of that
very often is that then faith lapses
into feederism and from there easily
enough to fanaticism since feederism
doesn't need to back itself up the fact
rationalism unfit ISM then in a strange
way I think become each other's mirror
image the other side of a
two-dimensional reason is is a
faith-based reality John Milbank writes
that where reason has retreated he says
there it seems faith has now rushed in
often with violent consequences reason
if reason if reason has trouble with
value then faith has trouble with fact
and the old value dichotomy is thereby
reintroduced fundamentalism is of course
among other things the visceral response
of those driven into a kind of spirit
spiritual zealotry by a shallow
technological rationality which leaves
all the most pressing cultural and
metaphysical questions scornfully to our
side and therefore leaves them open to
being monopolized by the rednecks and
the bigots neoconservatism
is of course i hardly say species of
feederism with its belief on troubles in
its ideological zeal by anything as
trifling as reality
conversely reason as I've said as I said
in last last lecture has to ground
itself in something other than itself to
be authentic not something which is
unreasonable but something which is
other than reason if it doesn't do that
if it grounds itself largely in material
interests and forms of political
Dominion rather than say in some idea of
peaceable community or some idea of
loving fidelity then faith and reason
will simply spin apart from each other
and each will become a caricature of
itself few years and rationalism again
there's another sense too of course a
very obvious sense in which a quality of
belief of faith leads to a surplus of it
which is simply but if the West really
did have faith in the Christian gospel
of peace and fellowship it wouldn't you
know
time doing things like killing arming
and championing those who kill our
children on the west bank and therefore
wouldn't have to worry quite so much
about people crashing its aircraft into
nuclear reactors in the name of Allah
once again the warmness of belief spawns
on the other side of itself a kind of
pathological surplus of it another
contradiction I will simply touch on
which the war on terror has helped to
foreground is that economic liberalism
of course generates mighty tides of
global migration of roots people from
their homes destroys or undermines whole
communities which then when it comes
home to the West so to speak generates
multi-cut a kind of multiculturalism
that's a problem however not only the
obvious sense that such multiculturalism
may be a breeding ground for terrorists
but in a more subtle sense that as I
think I said before culture is what beds
political power down culture is
necessary for all kinds of reasons not
least because superfluity is necessary
to us one definition of culture is that
which is which all flows the measure
which is not strictly necessary to us
biologically and as King Lear sees you
know a lack of I mean superfluities
though argue not the need superfluity is
part of what we are or need but also
because culture is important here
because if culture is what helps to bed
power down to naturalize domestic aid
make us live power on all our pulses our
bodies in our spontaneous behavior
because power if we know will only
survive in that way that is complicated
if there are too many cultures there on
the place that's complicated
if power has to bed itself down
simultaneously in a diversity of
cultures who might interpret it in
different ways I think one of the
problems of multiculturalism fit for the
powers that rulers is precisely that
it's not just getting people to live
well together it's precisely that part
of what's happened in our time you might
say is that God has shifted over from
the side of civilization to the side of
barbarism this is a momentous event he
may not know this but actually I was
telling him that it's true God is no
longer you know the short-haired blue
blazer to God of the West or if he is
he's that now almost entirely in the
United States and not in Porto or
Cardiff warble Anya yes but he is a
wrathful dark-skinned God who if he did
ever create John Locke or John Stuart
Mill has long ago forgotten about it
or might go further and claimed not only
that God has shifted over in our time
from the site of civilization to the
site of barbarism but that the new form
of barbarism is known precisely as
culture culture in a certain sense has
become the new form of barbarism the
age-old antithesis between barbarism and
civilization has been complicated at
least by the entry onto the stage of a
third term namely culture which is not
quite the one or the other but which
moment geopolitically speaking is in
dire danger of being identified with
barbarism what do I mean by that well I
mean that the conflict is now apparently
or is presented to us very often as one
between civilization meaning
individuality autonomy universality
rational speculation conscious judgement
and the like and culture which means
nothing at all like that
it means precisely all those supposedly
unreflective loyalties and allegiances
and inherited affiliations which are
apparently as built-in to us as our
liver or our pancreas which we can't as
it were get a fix on intellectually and
it would be a bad thing to do so
in certain ideologies of culture that in
the name of which men and women are
prepared to kill or to be killed they
may be prepared to kill or be killed in
the name of civilization that's what
people are supposed to be doing in Iraq
I suppose but they're certainly prepared
to be to kill or be killed in the name
of culture because that implicates their
identity not just no material interests
the problem however one problem how is
this that if there's an increasing
dichotomy between civilization and
culture in our world it's also true that
the two things really have to go
together they have to go together
because culture in the sense of them the
medium of lived experience and lived
identity has to be the medium of
abstract reflective universal values has
to be that to say the place where they
mediate themselves flesh themselves out
as forms of practical reason culture is
necessary for civilization as it's very
medium that there are medium which
conduct so to speak its values into the
interior of human subjects and embedded
them or to put the point a bit more
cynically
transnational corporations are
completely culturalist and unload eyes
din themselves in this sense alone they
resemble the Almighty if in no other
sense the Almighty is not cultural birds
of course transnational corporations
must pay sedulous attention to how
business is traditionally transacted in
Colombo or Chittagong you know they must
bring their global values or universals
to bear on specific cultural situations
if they're to make profit if they're to
if they ignore those specific cultural
mediations they will be at a
disadvantage yet there's also and this
is the problem surely there's also an
intense antagonism between these two
phenomena civilization of culture which
the cultural supremacists in the West
increasingly have mapped onto a West
East axis now that is of course among
other things to forget that Western
civilization is riddled with cultures
from end to end
you know gay culture beach culture
police culture and deaf culture the
world culture has X formed in our day to
cover a variety of groups and of course
that the closed culture of Islamism is
by no means a reflection of the
civilization of the Islamic world as a
whole so one of the most pressing
problems of our time I think is that
civilization can neither dispense with
culture nor can easily coexist with it
civilization is precious but fragile
culture is supposed to be red-blooded
and potent civilizations kill to protect
that protect their material interests
whereas cultures kill to defend their
identities and the more materialist and
hard-headed civilizations become the
more they breathe cultures as a reaction
to themselves to fulfill the kinds of
emotional and psychological needs which
civilization can no longer handle they
are in that sense the inheritors of
Romanticism which try to do something
the same that which is meant to mediate
universal values to people namely
culture locality particular traditions
particular census of identity ends up
turning progressively against those very
values culture is the repressed which
returns as a vengeance not released in
the form of fascism certainly a culture
but culture is also feminism and gay
rights and of course the most
astonishingly successful revolutionary
movement which the West has ever
witnessed
the name of which I will tell you
afterwards for a small fee if you're
interested in revolutionary nationalism
revolutionary nationalism is a culture
in all of those senses of culture of
identity unity and tradition symbol and
language all of which is then pitted
against what's felt to be a clapped-out
now I haven't much time to spare here I
was going to say I just very lightly
touched on all the marvelous things I
was going to tell you about without
having the embarrassment of having to
tell you about them in this case but
there's a sense in which religion falls
on both sites and will taneous lee of
this culture and civilization dichotomy
culture is of course you know is
religion is of course doctrine
institution authority choirs cathedrals
metaphysical speculation but it's also
culture Christianity begins you might
say as a culture and changes into a
civilization religion in the United
States my hunch is correct me if I'm
wrong is still something of a
civilization or what matter whereas in
England it's largely a sort of cultural
offender you know it's a traditional way
of life rather more akin to high tea or
clog-dancing you know than it is to say
socialism or Darwinism and it would be
bad form to take it too seriously I mean
one of the very on English aspects of
the otherwise egregiously English
Dawkins is getting so het up about
religion you know as the Englishman said
it's when religion starts to interfere
with your everyday life that it's time
to give it up
you know couldn't imagine them you know
the Queen's Chapel and asking you if
you've been washed in the blood of the
lamb poll polling in England reveals
that most of the English by large
majority actually feel that religion has
done far more harm than good okay I'll
just try and yes there are I just very
quickly touch on one of whose strategies
whereby you can try to get yourself out
of this dichotomy between civilization
and culture one of them is the sort of
one of the mr. Klain that civilization
has chosen as it were certain places
certain localities certain traditions in
which to incarnate itself in which to
make itself flesh
you know Geist in its wisdom has just
happened to hit on you know Paris as a
place to incarnation so if we stand in a
certain way brings the universal and the
local together at the cost of vast
applause ability a rather more
bold-faced attempt to do this as is is
the kind of attempt associated with
interesting postmodern attempts
associated with people like Richard
Rorty a name incidentally which I was
convinced meant something naughty so I
looked it up in the Oxford English
Dictionary and indeed the OED defines
Rorty as rowdy boisterous coarse earthy
and fun-loving which is not exactly how
I remember him
for this kind of case Western
civilization is indeed a culture in a
sense of being entirely local and
contingent you know among various other
cultures but it could the case claims
that its value should nevertheless be
treated as though they were universal
and foundational in a strange irony it
acknowledges that they're not
foundational but as it were you can
treat them as though they were you can
you know was abandon a rational defense
of your way of life for culturist one
but the price of doing so is letting
hold of any classical kind of
foundationalism all right let me just
say that yes I'll just end by saying
this the what we the upshot of this one
upshot of this is that we seem to be
faced globally with a rather unwelcome
with a dynamic with a rather unwelcome
entities the West either trusts in the
power of a post historical post
metaphysical post theological pragmatism
anti foundationalism in the in the teeth
of the absolutism and foundationalism of
its Islamic enemy and that's a risky
enterprise or it falls back upon
metaphysical values of its own as the
Western fundamentalist would insist but
that's what those values are looking
increasingly tarnished in certain places
outside the United States I mean in they
may in Dallas see God as you know the
great chief executive officer in the sky
but that's not likely to be a view
endorsed in Manchester or Minster so
does the West need to go metaphysical to
save itself is that what we need but if
it does can it do so without inflicting
too much down
on its liberal values thus ensuring that
there's still something worth protecting
from its illiberal antagonists Marxism
held out a promise of reconciling
culture and civilization there's a long
argument here that I can't now really
get into but mark because Marx is in a
set in a sense at once a good
old-fashioned enlightenment rationalist
concerned with universality and
individuality autonomy and also a good
old-fashioned romantic humanist
concerned above all with sensuous
specificity many hallmark marks
it's his dislike of abstractions for
what he sees as a sensuously specific in
some sectors on the other hand given the
enormous political rebuff that Marxism
has taken that battle has passed to
elsewhere and one of those places of
course I'm surprisingly in many ways is
theology I mean it's in some sectors of
theology nowadays that one can find the
most informed and animated discussions
of Delors and that you of Foucault and
feminism Marx and Heidegger and so on
not entirely surprising perhaps because
the theology is one of the most
startling ambitious theoretical arenas
left to us in an increasingly specialist
and fragmented world one who's subject
is nothing less than the nature and
destiny of humanity itself in relation
taught it takes to be its transcendent
source I mean you try erasing that kind
of question in analytical philosophy or
political science or even in some
theology at some some theological
departments my
quite embarrassed brother so we find
ourselves in a very curious and
incongruous situation we a world in
which indubitably theology is a massive
part of the problem and has become so in
new and unpredictable ways yes as ditch
concer rightly points out so rightly
once I've massively part from but where
it also seems to be fostering kinds of
critical reflectiveness which might just
lead to some answers will either side at
the moment in this debate you know
listen to the other well to use a
suitably theological term not a hope in
hell
what's the line which Ian foster ends
Passage to India not here not now not
yet it's not to say not ever but the
conditions have to be right and at the
moment for all kinds of geopolitical and
ideological reasons I think both sides
are far too entrenched and somehow
sometimes far too self-righteous to be
able to listen to it or not not one is
not able to listen to everything at any
time how far one can receive a message
is shaped of course by one's situation I
don't believe for a moment that any
unfortunately you know anything I've
said in these lectures will make a blind
bit of difference the beliefs of Richard
Dawkins or Chris Hitchens but that's not
to say that under different sort of
conditions instant conversions will
happen but we may be able to create the
material and ideological situations in
which some sort of more fruitful
dialogue is finally possible I just end
my sisters's alot of my lectures by
warmly thanking
Loreley the field for effortless
efficiency in bringing me over here and
making that whole business quite
painless as well as in her warm kindness
and hospitality which has helped being
here and being such a pleasure and also
a Blee assisted by Barbara Mordechai I'm
very very grateful I'm also grateful to
you for having taken the trouble to
attend so assiduously and actually to
listen to what I've said not to argue
with me too much you know but just
enough to make it seem as there's some
constructive dialogue there was and I
will finally just say that my son Oliver
is once again prepared to entertain the
masses that and he will do so after the
discussion in the reception room if
anybody wants to go along thank you